[Applause]
with my co-host for the hour Jay Shetty
and the hilarious baby rock
y Rock
all right will you guys play a quick
game of red flag yellow flag green flag
all right I'm gonna read something
hypothetical about a relationship or a
date hold up Brett if you hate it yellow
if you're neutral green if you are into
it but I definitely want to hear Jay's
take on this all right here we go
they're long-term goals don't match
yours
I think it's a red flag okay I'm
intrigued because I feel like I know
that people change all the time I get
this I talk about my astrologist Whitney
Howard she's amazing
um but I think from the beginning you
kind of have your goals kind of have to
align a little bit because as you change
and grow you might grow even farther
apart if you're not on the same page
from the beginning but what do I know
I'm single why did you hold up yellow
for neutral what can be done about that
so I think that you don't have to have
the same goals but you have to respect
each other's goals and so the yellow is
because you have to ask yourself do I
respect what that other person's goals
are and do they respect what mine are
but if you truly respect if you truly
value what what other people value it's
great it's great you're right you're
right
okay I just appreciate you so much and I
can't even handle it I okay you go on a
first date with someone but you don't
feel that initial Spark
s
yeah I'm gonna go yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean that can grow
right yes like I I'm definitely very
personality driven very sense of humor
very kind of goal oriented
um someone's abilities you know
um so certainly I I don't think I would
take that as a red flag yeah absolutely
yeah sometimes I think you know the halo
effect means we get impressed by one
thing that makes us feel the spark so if
someone's attractive we think they're
trustworthy if someone's smart we think
they must be organized and so the spark
isn't necessarily reality it's just a
feeling so sometimes you actually find a
deeper spark if you don't feel an
immediate spark that distracts you and
so it can be healthier too
wait Jay do you Jay do you have any
single friends do I you know I might
let's let's talk about okay okay
[Applause]
I don't know anyone who's like you Jay
Roddy is a lucky woman
all right when you go on date nights
with your long-term significant others
but you know you're just don't have
anything to talk about
um
that's bad yeah I mean I agree with be
if you're hanging out with your family
or your friends or you're cultivating a
life outside of the relationship you
will have things to talk about another
tip I have take it or leave it is show
up at the date do not watch each other
get ready and take the boring monotonous
drive with each other and then arrive at
the restaurant and be like well now
we've run out of everything to say show
up like it's fresh and new
that's awesome
[Applause]
all right Phoebe Robinson I love you so
much I love talking about the fact that
you are someone who publishes literature
and Empower authors out there and thank
you for talking about relationships
[Applause]
March 14th and catch Phoebe's upcoming
stand-up shows which tickets are on sale
now for because I tell you I cannot
navigate this life without laughing so
thank you for that Phoebe all right
you why I'm wearing red
[Music]